well you've now reunited with new
edition um uh for a tour
so how how is that going
we
we
look at that footage this is amazing we
actually just finished the tour yeah we
did a
30 city tour and it was it was
everything that i expected it to be
it was a lot of hard work yeah a lot of
dancing yeah a lot of laughing a lot of
joking around
just
this the camaraderie between all six of
us is just so much fun it was it was
like camp
it was like isn't it different because
you're all like older now so that's like
the thing i love like when i run into
people like even i've been in the
industry for 20 years and i run into
someone i'm like oh my god when i knew
you
i was just such a different human i feel
like you know what i'm saying like you
grow in like the conversation you have
kids you have like all that you know
life happens that's kind of that's gotta
be cool it was cool it was cool that all
of us are you know married and we have
kids and yeah grandchildren yeah you
know some of us have grandchildren now
and yeah it's like you know
um
it's beautiful you know to get all the
families together and all of us together
yeah and you know just just love upon
each other and you're like making so
many people happy on that stage
[Music]
you